Мама Наталія, донька Яна та син Ярослав. У такому ж складі торік, 8 квітня,
вони втрьох, тікаючи від війни, намагалися виїхати з Краматорська.
Саме тоді Росія вдарила по вокзалу балістичною ракетою з касетною боєголовкою.
Наталія втратила ліву ногу, а її 11-річна донька - обидві ноги.
Я збиралась виїжджати і не збиралась водночас.
Потім подзвонив чоловік, каже, збирайся, тому що буде ще гірше.
Ну, в нас тоді ще таких прильотів не було, ми тільки могли дивитися,
як Новоселівку бомбили, було видно.
На цих світлинах родина Степаненків у перші тижні після трагедії.
Відтоді близнюки Яна та Ярослав підросли.
Ось ця гривка така… Ну дитиночка така маленька. А зараз - ох.
Півтора року тому їм здавалося, що звичне життя закінчилося.
Нині ж, як колись, вони знову можуть вийти на прогулянку.
Ба більше - Яна вже пробігла свій перший півмарафон.
Понад рік Степаненки провели у Сан-Дієго.
Яна та Наталія пройшли протезування в одній з найкращих клінік США.
Тяжко було спершу, звичайно, але потім якось так звикли.
Яночка ходила у нас десь до жовтня.
Але після операцій, що їй робили в Україні, десь їй трохи закрутили нерв,
і в неї почалися болі.
У США вирішили, що треба оперувати. 4 листопада її прооперували.
Загалом Яна перенесла три операції. Останню робили вже у США.
У Яни була перша після цієї трагедії, друга була у Львові.
Їй прибирали кісточку, бо для протезування вона була зайвою.
Її треба було прибирати, Яна просто не могла ходити.
Прибрали. І третю вона вже перенесла в Штатах.
Та попри усі випробування Яна з посмішкою згадує перебування в Америці.
Це - я, а це - мама. Ми катались на американських гірках, нам зробили таке фото.
Це взагалі дуже страшно було. Я там так кричала, що просто капець.
І хоча Степаненки мали можливість залишитися у США - все ж вирішили повернутися до України.
За своєю мовою сумували, навіть за хлібом.
І сало купували там, але воно не зрівняється з нашим.
Сюди приїхали й я вже набрала і сала, і м’яса. Всього, щоб дітям готувати все.
Планів на майбутнє Наталія нині не будує, проте каже: хоче хоча б на день поїхати додому
- у донецький Нью-Йорк, який щоденно під ударами РФ. Там досі залишається її рідна тітка.
Ми жили в Новоселівці. Це поряд з нашим Нью-Йорком,
потім ми купили будинок у Нью-Йорку. В 2016 році ми переїхали,
діти пішли в школу, в садочок спочатку ходили, потім пішли в школу.
Так жили, все було нормально, все було гарно.
Діти росли собі, бігали, гуляли, їздили до бабусі нашої в Новоселівку.
Нині немає ані дому, ані бабусі. Мама Наталії загинула торік під час російського обстрілу.
22 березня її вбило, прилетів снаряд. Ми хотіли її звідти, звісно, забрати,
а в них вже не було зв'язку, світла не було.
Телефон так заряджали люди, ну в кого генератор був, то заряджала.
Ми вже не могли до неї додзвонитися. А на наступний день знайомий наш поїхав туди.
Він каже, ви не вмієте, мов, вмовляти. І він поїхав, навіть не сказав нам, що він поїде Тоню забирати.
І він вже її привіз мертву, тому що 22-го вбило її і вбила там ще сусіда Женю.
Чоловік Наталії, тобто вітчим близнюків, який воював у лавах ЗСУ, також загинув на війні.
Він з 2015 року воював. Ось як у 2015 його призвали… Це ми познайомилися.
Потім у 2016-2017 він у військкоматі був. І в січні  2022-го у нього контракт закінчився,
і він тільки 29 січня приїхав додому.
Я вже думала, що все, побуде якихось там 4-5 місяців вдома, відпочине,
а потім вже піде десь на роботу. І тут це.
Нині Степаненки живуть у Львові. Тут Яна готується до заміни протеза.
- А не натирає тобі, до речі, протез? - Та ні.
- Немає пролежнів, нічого? Все окей?
- Нормально.
Новий протез для Яни мають виготовити у майстерні реабілітаційного центру "Незламні".
Протези доведеться змінювати щороку, аж доки Яна не перестане рости.
У зв'язку з тим, що Яночка росте, її форма тіла постійно змінюється, змінюється форма ніг.
Їй потрібно буде ще кілька разів змінювати її протези.
Зараз у неї настав саме той період часу, коли потрібно знімати нові мірки
і розпочинати процес виготовлення нових протезів, які, я маю надію, прослужать їй ще потім рік часу.
Попереду у Яни ще одна реабілітація, а у Наталії як голови сім'ї надважлива місія
- влаштувати комфортне життя для дітей.
Поки що родина житиме у Львові, утім, Степаненки вірять - одного дня поїдуть додому.
Бо хоч вони й побували в Америці, але найбільше мріють
повернутися в свій український Нью-Йорк.